we like kids to know that all dreams are
possible if you believe in yourself
so you just might want to grab the
tissues
because natalia bryant turns 18 on
tuesday
and in honor of the big day her mom
vanessa bryant
hit up instagram to write one seriously
touching tribute to her oldest daughter
she's amazing i was there i was there
helping
you know doing everything i possibly can
to make the process easier for my wife
but ultimately
you know she did all the work i was just
there just trying to help
out the proud mama shared a few
throwback shots on
instagram writing in part quote happy
birthday
mommy and daddy are so proud of the
young lady that you
are you have displayed so much strength
and grace throughout the most difficult
year of our lives
very sad news to tell the sports world
the la times is reporting
that retired los angeles lakers
basketball star kobe bryant
has been killed in a helicopter crash
january 26th will mark the one-year
anniversary of kobe bryant and
13-year-old gianna bryant's tragic
deaths
and in her caption vanessa notes that
natalia has stepped up
amid her own grief to help their family
get through the
darkest days calling her an incredible
big sister
and a beautiful role model thank you for
being kind
polite and gracious in everything that
you do
you have no idea how happy and proud
mommy and daddy are that you're our
daughter
we love you always and forever forever
and always
our responsibility is to always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start
their journey with a leg up natalia's
milestone birthday comes just
days after her mama revealed that her
oldest born
might just have her heart set on going
to college in the big apple
posting this pic of the teen in a new
york university sweatshirt
and in the caption she said she's doing
what mamas do
trying to convince her daughter not to
fly too far from the nest
she wrote in part quote nyu is one of
her top schools
i will do my best to keep her and cali
just like i kept her daddy here
and it seems like vanessa might just get
her wish
shortly after she posted that nyu pic
she shared
this shot of natalya posing in a
university of southern california
t-shirt
giving a fight on to the camera you